south africa has had more than 2.3
million
covet cases and about 67 thousand deaths
but experts warn the real figure
could be three times higher a fragile
economy and political unrest led to
deadly violence in the country earlier
this month
disrupting supply chains and stretching
emergency services
now the delta variant is causing another
devastating covet surge
deborah pata is at a field hospital in
johannesburg good morning
good morning although south africa has
stepped up its inoculation drive
those shots arrived too late to halt a
rising death toll from a deadly third
wave driven by the delta variant
the incessant whaling of ambulance
sirens
this is the soundtrack of a third wave
raging through a largely
unvaccinated country paramedic mohammed
rasool has not had a jail for over two
months
currently very very busy multiple call
outs every day
how old are you every call out requires
urgent hospital care
uncle your oxygen levels are drastically
low
but there's a line for beds this
hospital is completely overwhelmed there
are no icu beds available
this patient is critical they need a bid
they will either have to wait outside
or try another hospital tears of relief
as space opens up for rasul's patient
but more often than not that means
someone else has died
oxygen is in desperate short supply
at least 50 canisters are delivered to
this state-run hospital
every day it is not enough
and every patient rasul collects has
critically low oxygen levels
nice deep breaths for me okay to
supplement the shortage
welcome this emergency field hospital
has been set up by volunteers
within hours of opening it was already
full i'm bringing the options and linda
she's very short of breath dr fatima
lumbert has been on the job non-stop for
16 months
you're exhausted already because you
haven't had a break since last year
march
and you still have to get up go on she
says
they are seeing more severe illness and
death this time round
and last week's violent insurrection in
south africa fueled by poverty and
hunger
has only made things worse medical
warehouses were looted
and critical supplies have been unable
to reach their destination
without a police escort there's a
shortage of oxygen right shortage of
oxygen also short of the veg put the two
together
it's a complete disaster all this
as the delta variant outruns the vaccine
despite the availability of pfizer and
johnson and johnson vaccines many sites
were shut down last week
further hobbling inoculation efforts and
now authorities are worried that the
violence could see a rise in covert
cases
putting pressure on hospitals already at
breaking point
another area we can learn from there